that one is going to be hard for people
to swallow because I've been dealing
with collectors for years and the only
thing they're good at is pestering the
crap out of you
and so the fact that you've not had a
single contact from anyone at the
hospital at the insurance company at
anywhere that the there's nothing came
in the mail nothing not one thing that
that's really hard to swallow
so you're gonna have trouble selling
that one to the judge
um if you go before either judge the one
on the collection or the one for the
thing so you better get your crap
together on that story
uh but the I'm not I'm not accusing you
of lying I just think I will tell you
that like one percent of the time I
would hear something like that happening
so um yeah it just doesn't happen so you
need legal advice is what I think and
it's more than I can give you because I
really don't know the law
in Kansas on that and that's that's what
you're looking at so Ken I actually got
a collections notice you did yeah
and I thought well this is a bogus like
as in recent times like 30 years ago
about about a year and a half ago okay I
gotta hear this and I just threw it in
the trash
because I'm like oh it's a complete scam
obviously I don't have that out for
collection obviously I don't have an
unpaid Bill oh my God you know I've got
a controller that pays our bills so
finally I I handed it to our attorney
the third time I came in I said call
this guy and get room he comes back in
he goes That's the time the ambulance
picked up your wife when she passed out
at the restaurant yes I said okay we do
owe that that gun no way and but I had
never like this guy I had never heard a
thing before I got a collections notice
the ambulance people never sent a bill
but um there's no way I have a bill it's
sure enough sure enough I did I was a
deadbeat oh there you go how that did
make national news I'll never well now I
will
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
open phones are
888-825-5225 Ken Coleman Ramsey
personalities my co-host Lexi is in
Harrisburg Pennsylvania hi Lexi how are
you
I'm good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
um so I just had a quick question I've
been
um listening to the show for about two
weeks now and I'm really trying to get
everything in order here
um I had a previous 401K with my
previous employer and I took it out
stupidly about a year and a half ago and
put the money in a CD
um paid the taxes and penalties then
when you filed your taxes right correct
yes I'm sorry
um yeah yeah
um I have twenty five hundred dollars in
credit card debt and then fifty nine
hundred dollars in student loans
um the CD comes due in January obviously
I'll be making payments
um and trying to get
done with this debt soon
four thousand okay I would not wait for
it to come in I'd cash it out now
pay off your credit card
okay and Lexi
cut it up
yeah yeah I really have to do that debit
card are you on a budget yet
yes sir I have every dollar good good
usually every dollar perfect that's
exactly what you need to do so that
gives you the sense that I'm in control
and I don't need a credit card because
I'm only going to spend money that I
have right
right yeah good good how old are you
25. you are right on track you aren't
doing so good what a great turn in two
weeks you've made
very proud thank you sir that's very
difficult to do you've already done some
difficult things you got ahead of it got
on top of it made it behave with the
every dollar app the budget is you
telling your money what to do instead of
wondering where it went and using every
dollar to do that was brilliant and you
know now we got rid of the credit card
now we got less of student loan right
and you got right yeah and you got
fifteen hundred dollars in your account
left because we didn't use the whole
four thousand so baby step one is save a
thousand have you heard us yet talk
about the baby steps
mm-hmm you have
yeah yeah I have my emergency fund set
up so I'm on step two so you have you
have um one thousand dollars in addition
to this CD
correct yeah good okay then take the
other 1500 and throw it at the student
loan so that brings us from 5900 down to
forty four hundred
now you got four thousand four hundred
dollars in debt left what do you make
how much can you squeeze out a month to
throw at this debt
um I mean you're living on nothing now
beans and rice you're not going out to
eat you're not going out on the weekends
you're not going on vacation we're
getting this debt gone
yeah yeah I would say probably around
400 extra a month I could do okay I want
you to jack that up I don't want you to
pick up a side gig I'd love for you to
be debt free by Christmas you only got
four thousand dollars to do that so you
need about a thousand bucks a month
show you now you're free for Christmas
and when you start 2024 you're a whole
new person you're ready to get in attack
mode I really like where your head is
right now you're you're the way you're
thinking is the way people think when
they turn the corner on this whole money
subject and they get control they get
out of debt and later you're gonna
become a millionaire because you did
this
awesome well thank you so much sir you
can do this have you got a copy of Total
Money Makeover yet
no I do not I'm gonna send that to you
as a gift proud of you very very well
done Ken that's a big start huge and you
heard her say in two weeks so there's
some real momentum that she's created in
a very small window of time yeah you you
change
you know you go okay I can't do that
anymore okay can't do that anymore oh
I'm gonna start doing this not doing
that doing this not doing that doing
this and you start having a new list and
you say this is who I am and as our
friend James Clear says in atomic habits
you start saying I am not a person who
borrows money you don't say oh oh how
can I not borrow money you just say I am
going to I did my change my identity now
the way I talk about myself in my head
which is where people are the meanest by
the way when they're talking to
themselves uh well the way I talk about
myself is now I'm on my way to being a
baby steps millionaires when we talk to
a guy at the breakout he paid off a half
a million dollars maybe became a baby
steps millionaire yeah just a minute ago
and uh you know I mean and I you know
it's just freaking that's like turn a
mountain down man oh yeah it's a big
deal you don't do that crap you don't
win at that level on an accident but you
can almost hear the resolve in her voice
oh yeah you could tell that she had
already bought it now she was trying to
figure it out she's bought the
philosophy yeah she she that's the part
and then she was like okay good and even
just the politeness I mean she's not a
kid but just the thank you sir there's a
humility a spirit of oh my goodness
gratitude I have figured out that this
can be done and I'm on my way and see
she's Unstoppable she'll never waver
yeah versus somebody calls and Trust to
talk me into doing letting them and
endorsing their stupidness that is my
favorite Dave you've talked to
7642 people on this particular topic
this week are you sure that's not true
for me what about me should I borrow
money at 1.99 on my car
and put that money into a CD Dave as if
you're gonna go you know what you know
what just for you I think we're gonna do
a special dispensation yeah just for you
we need to give you some kind of like
where you go all right I will give you
like gravity works for everyone I'm
gonna give you an exception and an
exception not for you the law of gravity
does not apply to you that's it it's a
law but it's not it's not a law and
here's what's funny about that we're
joking around but that's actually
illustrating
why she's gonna why she's gonna win
because she she's already got it she
believes it those people still doubt it
and they think that if they ask you
another way that you're going to
identify a crack yep oh I never thought
of that yeah 30 years Austin in
Huntington West Virginia hey Austin
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Ken uh I was just wondering how can
I well we gotta find the job first
uh the Direction first in fact it's less
about job it's more about path the type
of work is what I'm talking about and
then we go doesn't require a degree to
do that thing
so my guess is you have a couple of
ideas yes
yes uh I'm I'm good with computers and
audio and things like that great all
right let's take those two different
things let's separate those let's say
just computers we'll just say that's the
technology path I can tell you right now
you don't introduce you don't need a
degree there are all kinds of let's just
take one example of coding boot camps
there are uh certifications in cyber
security let me tell you design so those
are three specific jobs within a
technology path where you don't need a
degree and I would tell you I endorse
Bethel technology uh Ramsey Solutions
works with them they've got a nine month
program less than fifteen thousand
dollars and I just got another report
yesterday
of a single mom who was making 39 000
just took a job for 85. yep no college
degree so this is real stuff this isn't
hype now let's look at the the audio
side by the way we hire him at Ramsey we
hire them yeah we do from Bethel Tech
that's right and they're great I mean
it's just because we need coders and
they're making you know they're making
Banks that's right uh betheltech.net for
our listening audience and viewing us if
you want to just check them out tell
them Ken and Dave sent you uh but let's
talk about the audio side so here we are
in the shadows of Nashville right Music
City audio Engineers can do very very
well and again no college degree
necessary so what you did now do Austin
is a thing I call the proximity
principle and I'm going to give you that
book here when we put you on hold in a
minute I was a best-selling book and
here's what I want you to do over the
next 30 days I want you to be very
intentional to spend some time in person
or on the phone or Zoom with with people
that are in those different fields so if
you're interested in more the design
side of tech go that route if you're
interested in more of the coding side of
of tech or cyber security find somebody
who knows somebody in that industry and
just ask them questions like you were
doing a high school term paper same
thing the audio side the reason is I
want you to get an idea of what their
Journey was get an idea of what they do
day in Day Out The Good the Bad and the
Ugly and the reason I want you to do
this is because it allows your head to
process this information and then your
heart kind of goes ding ding ding or
gives you that X sound so hang on the
line we'll get you the proximity
principle which is going to give you
much more detailed clear path to get
around people that are doing what you
think you want to do so that you figure
out if it is the thing you want to do
we have never we got a bunch of audio
Engineers on the team a bunch of
computer tech folk on the team of all
kinds and we've never not hired one of
those because they did not have a
four-year degree not one time all we
want to know is can they do the freaking
job that's all we care this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their
watch and guarantee and
hands-free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsay personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your Hub
hub for Home Services
neighborly.com is the place to find
Reliable help for your home from locally
owned businesses like Air Serv dryer
vent wizard Precision garage door
service window Genie and more for expert
help with just about anything you need
visit neighborly.com today's question
comes from Aaron in Illinois I recently
voluntarily surrendered a truck I owed
56 000 on and then they sold it at
auction for forty thousand now I'm
finding out they can put a lien on my
house or garnish my wages what should I
do I'm looking into filing bankruptcy or
trying a debt settlement company
yikes yeah okay so a voluntary repo is a
repo
and guess what they do with repoed cars
they sell them on the repo lot and guess
what they do with the difference the
deficit they expect you to pay it so
yeah they have you know you now have a
sixteen thousand dollar debt instead of
a fifty six thousand dollar debt
um so for any of you that have friends
or relatives or any of you that think
you can just turn a car in
and it automatically wipes out the debt
um here's your life lesson you can't
it doesn't they're going to come after
you for the difference
that's the bad news so the good news
Aaron is a debt settlement company can
help you and the good news is you're not
bankrupt you can settle a car def repo
deficit for somewhere around a quarter
on the dollar so you owe sixteen
thousand dollars that means somewhere
around four thousand bucks will settle
this so long before they sue you and
they haven't suited you yet they haven't
even bothered you yet it takes them a
while repo on a car they usually don't
get around to it for 12 14 months after
the repo so um
but they they are going to come calling
so let's not pretend like this is not
going to happen you're not bankrupt
though you need four or five thousand
bucks cash in an account to offer them
as settlement in full negotiate that out
and if you don't have four or five
thousand which I'm guessing you don't
you just turned your car in so you're
probably broke
so what are we gonna do we're gonna go
get four or five thousand bucks where do
we get that we deliver pizzas we walk
dogs we
uh sell everything Uber eat we sell
everything sell so much stuff the kids
think they're next we
get in gear and we get on a tight tight
budget we don't got to eat well we have
four thousand dollars five thousand
dollars six thousand dollars hanging
over our head looking like a lawsuit we
don't go on vacation with your broke
brother-in-law because you're broke and
you're in debt and people are getting
ready to sue you you live on nothing and
you pile up money guess what you can
find four or five thousand dollars if
you do that you can in four or five
months or sooner so go get you some
money
that's what I'm gonna tell you and then
call these goobers and offer them to
settle they're not going to settle in
the first phone call this is not a
pleasant situation
this is a situation where you haven't
paid someone what you owe them
and they are going to use the law and
every technique they can to squeeze
every dime out of your turnip butt it's
what they do okay so you're gonna have
to argue with them you're gonna fuss
with them you're gonna say all I got is
five thousand dollars you want to assume
me you can sue me because I can't do
anything but they cannot put a lien on
your house and they cannot garnish your
wages until they have sued you and one
and then that either one of those other
two things is called executing on the
judgment
now um
different states have different laws as
to how aggressively you can execute
Texas for instance you don't get a lien
on your house they won't let you uh
other states I think Texas won't allow
garnishment even so uh very friendly to
the consumer State uh Illinois may allow
them to come take your firstborn I don't
know I don't know what what the law says
okay but uh you know you can find that
out but here's the thing it's none of
it's going to happen fast and none of
it's going to be a surprise and there's
not a single state where they can take a
lien on your house or
garnish your wages on a car repo deficit
without first having gone to court and
one
so you're gonna have all kinds of
warning and opportunities to settle with
the people with the people's attorney
with in front of the judge you're gonna
have all kinds you can even settle the
Judgment after the court has rendered a
judgment you can settle that for pennies
on the dollar uh and all of that will
stop this from happening doing nothing
means they may take your house
and sell it for this debt doing nothing
means they will garnish you if they can
so doing nothing is a really stupid butt
idea but if you'll be active and get
some money piled up and just be
bothering them as much as they bother
you you can get this settled and you can
get it out of your life always do
everything in writing and no electronic
access to your bank account when you're
settling a debt because these people in
this business are some of them are
straight up but a lot of them are filthy
and so you they'll come clean out your
account and you've got six thousand in
there you settle for four they'll take
the whole six try getting that other two
back when you owe them 16 never happen
so don't no electronic access your
checking account cashiers check
something like that wire transfer
whatever it is but no access to your
account and of course have to have it in
writing that this is settled in full the
entire deficit balance on said
surrendered truck is settled for 4 462
or whatever it is you finally agree with
after arguing and arguing and arguing
and arguing but you're not bankrupt and
a debt settlement company can't help you
they don't do a good job with debt
settlement and they don't take this kind
of debt settlement anyway and so you're
going to get screwed again if you start
trying to figure out somebody else to do
this for you you got to go do it you're
in charge of you it's like a full-time
job Nikki said what hey Nikki welcome to
the Ramsay show
hi Dave and Ken okay need help I'm 63.
already kind of
hit recently I'm just
I'm just stressed out at work and just
kind of tired of it and want to know
need your opinion I currently live in
Kansas I have a house thinking about
selling moving to Tacoma Washington to
be closer to my son and adorable
granddaughters and just trying to figure
out if that's a crazy idea
based on what it costs to live in Kansas
versus what it costs to live in
Washington State
so I can can I share some numbers with
you sure
okay so um
I have about 400k and my 401ks 50 of
that is Roth
um
I make 155 gross
my house I owe
and don't yell I have a twenty thousand
dollar HELOC at a crazy 10 interest
um it is on the on a on three years into
a 15-year fixed on it what's about
what's on Earth
I think it should be 285 from who I've
talked to
okay
um and then
um what I was thinking is that then I
could just go to Tacoma I actually found
a lower level of a house
um to rent possibly at eighteen hundred
dollars a month with all utilities
included and take you know a year to get
to know the area decide where I want to
live
um you know take whatever I make from
this house just kind of you know stick
it in the bank and try to add to it and
then
um you know go that direction I am just
nervous about retirement
um I hadn't really thought about
retiring like today six months a year
does it take for you to live if you live
this retirement life how much do you
need a month
um I mean I would like to have
you know five thousand you're not you
don't have it
well you would you might with Social
Security
you know so if your 400 made 10 that's
40 000 a year
okay that's 3 300 bucks a month
with Social Security that's putting 100
down on a house the hundred from your
other old house
right so
yeah I I think you're going to
experience a real lifestyle shot going
from 155 000 income to a 40 000 income
I don't think you're that tired of that
work yet I could be wrong I mean
mathematically I'd love for you to work
a couple more years mathematically
because I'd love for that 400 to turn
into 600 or 700 uh it would change the
whole equation because it's pretty tight
and I'd like you to consider making the
move to making 155 or higher in Tacoma
keep all working but you're near those
beautiful grandbabies
that would be the option I'd look at
first I don't think you could quit
working yet so we're closer to them find
find some different work that makes some
money you're not done yet
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five marks in
Nashville hi Mark how are you
I'm fantastic how are you doing today
better than I deserve what's up
uh well I'm going to ask uh if it's a
good decision or a short-sighted
decision to cash out what happened my
401k thus far
that I was contributing to before I
started on the baby steps in order to
pay off my student loans faster hmm
how much is in your 401k
uh not like a ton
um I have about 27 and a half and I use
an online calculator that said that if I
after penalties and everything I'd get
about 20 19 or 20.
yeah you get hit a 10 penalty plus your
tax rate so it'll be somewhere between
30 and 40 percent of it goes to the
government for taking it out early so
it's kind of like saying Dave I want to
borrow money at 35 interest to pay all
my student loans
nope nope nope
not doing that one
no we don't Cash Out retirement early to
pay debt and because of that it's just
the the cost is too high so
um so how much student loan debt have
you gotten
now what do you make
about 50
how much is your car payment
I don't have one I bought a car cash
good good for you what other debts have
you got other than the 56 000 student
loan
um I have a small medical debt but uh
that's it oh good you single
I sure am yeah okay all right well what
I would do if I woke up in your shoes my
sir my friend is I would
um roll up my sleeves and attack it with
an absolute Vengeance because I have
found in 30 years of doing this that the
faster you get out
um the more likely you are to get out
and uh the people who try to bump along
and half butt you know keep it around
like it's a pet they don't make it out
and so I'm gonna go just like crazy like
where my broke friends think I joined a
cult crazy right I'm going nuts like
nothing I'm not going out to eat I'm not
going on vacation I'm gonna pick up
three extra jobs and we'll sell
everything in sight and if you put 25
000 a year on this you'll be done in two
years but that's you living on nothing
if you uh put 30 on it you'll be done in
14 15 16 months that's because you're
working extra and living on nothing but
that's the kind of thing I'm saying is
just take a an 18-month period of time
and go berserk and be done with this
otherwise it's going to be around for 10
years
yeah I completely agree I mean in 10
years of paying it I've barely made a
dent so you can't you can't you just
can't get rid of them they're just it's
like a bad mother-in-law joke I mean you
just it's awful so Mark fun question
here all right and I want you to be
conservative but I want you to to throw
a number at me if you really got after
it extra jobs selling stuff I mean just
really intense like Dave said what do
you think is the number you could come
up with the amount of money that you
could throw at this loan could you do 2
000 a month fifteen hundred three
thousand I mean you really went after
what's the number you think's realistic
yeah doing some of those calculations I
think what I landed on was that the
absolute Max before I'm starting to have
to cut into bills or like get the
internet turned off is about 1800 a
month that's without you making any
extra money
correct yeah that's like if I'm paying
rent and that's it yeah that's what do
you do for a living
I work for I'm an I.T professional for
an eyeglass company okay freelance work
my man like how much money could you
make with your I.T skills yeah
Contracting additional money Contracting
workout in the evenings oh my gosh dude
yeah I've never looked into that I don't
know anything about freelancing I.T
three or four thousand bucks a month
that's your homework assignment easy
look at your skill set all the search
you have you know your world better than
we do but I'm telling you if you've done
it you've done an unusually good job
yeah for someone who's new to this
material that we teach yeah you know
this is fair this whole Ramsay thing's
fairly new to you so I can tell by the
way you're talking but the uh and that's
not bad but you've done an unusually
good job of analyzing your situation and
you've already cut deep if you could get
2 000 a month out of your budget and put
three on top of it that's five you're
done in 10 12 months dude yep that's the
exercise the beauty of this whole call
is you've got an untapped Reservoir
called it side jobs that's going to pay
really good it might even open up a
career for you that you didn't even know
you had advancement in this in this
thing it's absolutely incredible so Ken
this student loans are top of mind right
now because they're starting they're
going to start paying them again in
October that's right and um
you know the first thing that happened
was there was false hope people have
kind of gone through the um yes the
stages of grief right it's really false
hope that Biden was going to forgive the
dead and then what's the false hope and
it was false yep those of us that know a
little bit about it told you it was
false but that people held out anyway
okay false hope now then it turned to
anger
but you know and our denial anger
and now it's moving to fear sure because
I'm looking up and I've got 900 a month
and I'm going to have to work in extra
jobs and I'm not gonna see my kids and
I'm scared and so uh what we're doing I
was just in a meeting a few minutes ago
talking about the content that we're
building out for this student loan live
stream event on September the 12th uh
Tuesday night just about two three weeks
away is all yeah uh just the Tuesday
after Labor Day right so uh you know
guys you got to get this down student
loan live stream ramsesolutions.com
student loans Rachel Cruz and Jade
warshaw and I are going to do an event
now this is not to talk about how
horrible student loans are we that's
kind of a given we don't really need to
do a live event for 100 000 people to
yell at you and tell you how stupid
student loans are we all kind of know
that now but we've you know what we want
to do is I we know you're getting you're
some of you are getting have woken up
enough that you're scared and some of
you are still just freaking into Nile
we'll smack you around a little too but
but it because denial is not just a
river in Egypt but the uh but the the
ones that are scared you know our
company is called Ramsey Solutions
so we're going to bring you some
solutions yeah for your student loan
debt and some of it was what we were
just talking to Mark about I mean
there's not any we don't have a magic
pill we don't have a a financial hack
for yours too you know the financial
hack is you get you a mirror baby I'll
go ahead spoiler alert I'm gonna tell
you what we're going to tell you right
but if you've got student loans bearing
down on you and um
you know you're a little bit mad about
it or you're a little bit scared because
it's coming down at you or you've got
someone in your life that that's going
on that then they don't know what to do
they're discombobulated confused
overwhelmed with the awkwardness of this
thing coming at you man I got to tell
you there's like 40 million people in
America right now that need some
solutions
and the that's the bad news the good
news is we got the solution we can help
you
but you can do it Ramsay Solutions
completely free live stream September
the 12th student loan live stream
ramseysolutions.com student loans sign
up today
we'll send you the link you can watch
the thing completely for free Rachel
Cruz Jade washout Jay paid off 265 000
in student loans she knows from whence
she speaks yeah and I would just want to
challenge those of you who listen and
watch on a regular basis this show is
encouraging you it's equipping you to
move forward would you just commit to
posting on social media
ramseysolutions.com student loans if you
can't remember that go to
ramseysolutions.com click on our events
page the details will be there let
people know that this is a free event
they can watch anywhere from their phone
their device uh whatever because Dave
this message there's a lot of people who
don't know about us yet and if you say
hey these people I trust I listen and
watch these people you're the greatest
recommendation that we could ever have
and say look they're helping me get out
of debt don't let this student loan
repayment freak you out we've helped
we've helped more people get out of debt
than anyone yeah walking the Earth today
yeah so tell people uh we post it we can
do it I mean it's not magic and it's not
easy and I'm not going to tell you it's
you know three easy steps and you're
gonna no no it's not it's gonna be a
pain in the butt yeah but you got a big
old mess honey it's not going to be easy
that's right you got a lot of manure to
shovel so expect to expect expect us
some stink right that goes with the
territory kills with overalls but I can
help you with this yeah you know you'll
have a callous when you're done but I
can help you I can show you what to do
and we have helped a bunch of people so
please yeah get signed up for this
student loan live stream and it's all
about helping you have a solution to the
problem not just barking about the
problem
ramseysolutions.com student loans free
live stream register right now this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsay win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Ken Coleman
Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose and host of the Ken Coleman
show on Ramsey networks is my co-host
today he talks a lot about jobs and
careers and work you got questions about
that this would be a good day for you to
jump in and do that but we're going to
help you with whatever you need we're
talking about your life triple eight
eight two five five two two five Jackson
Baltimore hey Jack how are you
hey Dave and Ken thanks for taking this
call sure I'm just going to find out
um if I should move forward with uh
selling my home or taking the chance
um to remain in it and possibly sell it
next summer uh here's the issue that's
going on right now currently behind uh
close to seventy thousand dollars uh on
my mortgage you're behind seventy
thousand dollars
yes how much is your house payment
house payment is
about 20 about 2300 so that's about two
and a half three years
how in the world have you gotten two or
three years behind they haven't
foreclosed on you
oh it was covered yeah okay yeah so
they're just now getting around to you
the post coveted foreclosures are
catching up now okay so have they
started foreclosure yet
no they haven't uh I went through the
Lost mitigation process which was a
grueling process my application was
accepted
I did receive a a trial payment plan
this past Saturday the the payments uh
well it's a three-month payment plan uh
the payments are feasible definitely can
afford it
um however
on this past Monday I received a letter
from my lender stating that my uh my
loan was being sold
to a new lender what kind of a loan do
you have FHA V A or conventional uh
VA loans okay the launch mitigation was
approved by the VA then the lender it'll
go with the loan
okay the new lender will the new lender
will honor this
okay all right and then the other thing
is we during this process since we was
waiting to hear back uh if we were going
to basically receive a payment plan or
not we put our house on the market uh we
did receive an offer uh if we were to
move forward with the offer
um it can potentially after the payoff
amount met us uh I'm close to 100K
okay so let me ask you this why um why
are you three years behind on your house
uh lost income
for three years
yeah
okay are you back why did you lose why
did you not work for three years
disability reasons
okay
um so was the disability permanent
uh yes it's permanent and I just started
back working again within the means of
my disability so what do you make
uh right now household with my wife
about just a little over 200k as of
right now
get the new job what was the nature of
your disability sir
um
you're going to I mean from physical
ailments to mental elements I'm a uh 100
disabled veteran oh okay okay well thank
you for your service yes sir
um which is another reason you got lost
mitigation from the VA okay
um
how long have you lived in this house
uh for about
five years I believe about five years if
I'm in your shoes and I've been through
the hell that you all have been through
um the last thing I want to do
is uh walk through mud knee-deep for the
next many many many many months trying
to get current
when I have a good offer on the table
that gives me a fresh start
I'm selling this puppy and taking a
fresh start clean take the white board
erase everything off the Whiteboard now
we got a fresh clean Grace filled
windshield looking forward
if I look in the rear view mirror I'm
going to see some piles of poop but
looking out the windshield is clean
you follow me
yes and I really personally like that
kind of fresh start feeling you've got a
real opportunity to do that here
um it involves moving which is a pain in
the butt but you know you make 200 a
year you got 100 in your pocket and this
problem is gone
I really like that yeah
okay you see why do you get it's not
really a financial thing as much as it's
emotional and you're going to end up
either way you're going to end up with a
house but you're going to have to go
through
I mean every time you pay double triple
payments it's like a a bell going off in
your head reminding you of the
disability you just clawed your way
through
but if you don't have that you just got
a fresh new life then you've got a fresh
new life you know you don't have
something reminding you of the past
every time you write a dadgum check you
know what I'm talking about
totally understand and I I just think
there's some mental health to that if
I'm in your shoes now I've never been in
your shoes literally where I served and
I you know came home
uh
you know with with disabilities uh and
I've never had that problem but I have
had the problem of my past following me
around we all have had that problem
right
and so I I just I can relate to you in
that regard and I just I personally love
a very clean
Fresh Start that's why I like when
someone uh for instance goes through a
divorce make sure that everything is
paid and clear and clipped we don't keep
paying payments together we're not
married anymore get it all cleaned up
get it separate you want the X to be an
X you know you don't want a half but
still be tied in well we got the kids so
make that the only thing you got
together everything else needs to be
clean because that way you can get on
with the second chapter of your life the
third chapter of your life whatever it
is you can't close the last chapter and
I just want to close your last chapter
for you because I care about you and I
just I hear it in your voice I want the
cleanliness I'm taking the deal I'm gone
yeah and take your time if you've got to
rent for a season yeah do it you got a
great combined income yeah assuming that
you're looks like you're pretty healthy
you're cleared uh the best is yet to be
here and I think Dave is absolutely
right I wouldn't even think twice about
this I would clean it all up and begin
the process of re-entering he's been in
a long season of healing and hurting and
all the stress of the house I absolutely
agree Dave I think you absolutely right
here this is new Square I think you're I
think your wife's gonna feel like that
you took a uh you know actually been
walking around carrying something on her
shoulders and she gets to set it down
yeah like breathe Yeah clean
cool Mountain Air
peace that's what I want here that's
what I'm after and I want to just on
behalf of David our entire audience
point out that Jack's a true American
hero a great American that would put his
life on the line to serve our country
and have to deal with all this junk uh
this is this is tough stuff and we're
really hoping and praying and cheering
you on that this next chapter is going
to be the best so thank you for who you
are and uh you got this we're going to
walk alongside of you you got it Jack
this is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Lindsay is in Bangor
Maine hi Lindsay welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi David Ken thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
well um my father passed away this
Sunday and why
yeah two days ago
yeah two days ago I'm so sorry how old
was he
uh he was 62. young
what was his name yeah
Michael
so what are you in your 30s
I'm so sorry what happened to me
he had um cancer so it's been coming a
while
yes about a year yeah oh my honey how
can we how can we help
well
um he he left
um me with some money and I'm I'm kind
of freaking out because part of it
um was cash that he gave to my aunt to
give to me upon his death but he had
just been saving
um and then part of it is
several smaller life insurance policies
um and his house and vehicles
and some other cash in the bank and
I am back at baby step one again for the
second time
um dude I had a baby and then
um our income went down so we've been
working on
um getting back to baby step two and
restarting the debt process again we
paid off about 30. so you're his you're
his sole heir
all right well
um I have two brothers that also are
receiving a portion of
um
one of his life's insurance policies but
they didn't have a relationship so he he
left a majority of it to me
um so it's hard to sell you have a car
to sell a house to sell
you get I assume there's a will
um
not the most is the money I have already
the 17
000 he had in savings
um that I my aunt just deposited in my
account yesterday I just I'm very
worried that I I was hoping to be
through my that free Journey
um before he passed so I wouldn't he
worked his whole life
um to save and to leave something behind
and maybe he was extremely Frugal and
didn't spend money on himself because he
wanted to have some money
um for us and what are you worried about
I don't wanna
I'm I'm worried that
the money is just I wanted
to honor him and I want to be a
responsible Handler of this money and I
am worried where we're back in baby step
one I don't
I don't know how to handle it I don't
know if I should use it towards our debt
free journey I I had thought about
giving it back to my aunt and having her
hold on to it for me for a little while
and keep working the plan as we were
um
let's stop a second okay
if someone I love this dearly died two
days ago
this is not the decision I need to make
right now
okay you're you're trying to talk
through
um
a heart that's hurting
and make math decisions
so what I want you to do is take the 17
000 out of your account go up in a
savings account
a six-month CD or three month CD
and it's not attached to your checking
in any way
and just pretend like it's not there for
a little while
get you you do not need the weight of
losing your father and the weight of
worry about you misbehaving with the
money at the same time
yeah it's too much it's too fresh it's
too raw
and you give yourself room to cry
okay
and let's just let's just let's just
hurt about
losing him for right now
and we'll worry about the money stuff
when we can breathe a little better
is that okay
yeah yeah
so here's what I want you to do I want
you to work through the estate stuff as
whenever you can but just keep it all
separate for two or three four months
five months and get where you can
breathe and then when your head is a
little more clear because you're a human
being that loved it loved her dad okay
you got to give yourself a little room
for that
and when your head's a little bit more
clear then you sit down with your
husband I take it you're married the way
you've been saying this right
yes okay well you kept saying we are on
baby steps I'm making sure and you you
just had a baby so that's what I was
going with okay so
um
you sit down and say all right we're
gonna go through Financial Peace
University and we're we're gonna
dial this in we're gonna get on the
every dollar budget and we're gonna work
these baby steps exactly
and we're going to use Dad's Legacy to
do that but the only way I can do that
and keep my sanity is to know that we
never go back
we have it our habits are permanently
changed you and him have to make a
a packed pinky swearing spit Shake right
you have to make a contract with each
other because the the what's scaring you
is is that you're gonna your dad works
so hard and you're gonna mess this up
that's what's scaring you
and what keeps you from messing it up is
two things one is you commit to this
system
and two is you and your husband make a
pact that we are sticking to this and
the reason we're doing that is to honor
the legacy of my dad because that's
where this freaking money came from
and so you have a real reason to do this
right going forward don't you
yeah yeah
yeah but you don't need to do any of
that today
that's later on when you can breathe
and the bad news is is that we're having
this conversation today the good news is
it's on a podcast and you can listen to
it in four or five months and it'll make
more sense
ah
is that okay
yeah yeah and we're gonna help you we're
going to put you through Financial Peace
University we're going to pay for it
okay so you hold on and Austin will get
you signed up and you can get on every
dollar but I would just take any go work
through get in the household the car
sold and every time something sells or
you get another chunk of money in from a
life insurance policy just throw it all
in that savings account just keep that
side savings account and you get a big
old pile of money over there that's
continuing to add up and then when your
head clears you can take that money and
drag it right over into the baby steps
and go but that's after you have some
confidence
from a contract with your husband that
we're never going to do anything except
these baby steps exactly this way and
you have some confidence that you've
dialed it in you believe that you're
going to do it because you you you're
going to have a different kind of broken
heart call regret and that's what you're
afraid of if you mess this up and you're
not going to mess it up because now you
got a real why honoring your dad's
Legacy is a great why yeah you need to
forgive yourself Lindsay we've all done
done with money we've talked about it on
the air and there's a there's something
hanging on you right now and I think
what you have to do beyond what Dave
said is you just got to forgive yourself
you just gotta know I'm not an idiot I'm
not a and and I've got a plan
though and the plan helps you're just
like everybody so we fell back we're on
baby step one again that's right so I
remember when I went bankrupt I had to
do that yeah uh it took me a little
while it not only stole my confidence
sure but I also was pretty pissed at
myself and so I finally had to come to
this real conclusion with the language
in my head is just because I did some
stupid things does not mean I am by
definition stupid that's correct that's
right smart people sometimes do stupid
things and I was a smart person they did
a bunch of stupid things and it bit me
in the butt well welcome to Being Human
yes and so I can forgive myself for that
it's but I'm not going to identify I'm
not gonna say my new identity a stupid
person correct no my new identity is a
person who never does those stupid
things again that's right that's my new
identity I'm tired of learning that
thing over and over it's time to move I
got plenty of new stupid stuff I don't
need to do the old ones twice correct
you know there's always that chance hey
hang on we'll get you signed up kiddo if
you need some more help you call us
anytime this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America Amy is with us in Chicago hi Amy
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up my question is is it conduct or debt
that you've paid off to come off your
credit report but then return on your
credit report the next month
um a little bit of context we just
finished maybe step two in July um my
husband and I paid off 28 000 in student
loans in July uh it came off of our
credit reports and then last week I got
an email saying our score was increased
by 78 points
um and then our loans are listed again
okay
um
no that's not common
um it's um so here's the thing 52 of the
credit reports have errors
36 of them have errors that are so
egregious it could keep you from getting
credit
yeah okay so This falls in the category
of error obviously and I think I know
how it happened I'm not 100 sure what to
do about it there's a couple of things
you can try but
um uh what happens is that these massive
companies in this case the student loan
servicer they do downloads usually
quarterly to the uh of their database to
the uh to the credit bureaus okay so
what happened was a single item
was removed as a single item and then
when they downloaded their latest data
it still had your student loan in it
they hadn't taken it out of that piece
of data so when they did the batch
download you were in the batch again
that's what put it back on there I'm
pretty sure
okay okay so if I would do two things to
get it off number one call the idiots
this is the problem with student loan
services they're absolute morons
I mean it's just you've had to deal with
them before right I mean it's like oh
yeah like are your parents cousins I
mean what is wrong with you people you
know it's just they can't find their
butt with both hands it's ridiculous how
inept they are so but there's nothing
you can do about it except fight through
the bureaucracy so
call them like 62 times because that's
what it'll take and tell them to get the
stupid thing off your credit report
again because it's paid off
would you please note the file is zero
balance now please turn that into
whoever who is it Experian or who is it
yeah experience yeah and and poor
Experian they're dumb as they are too
because they just take whatever these
people send them and load it on there
right with no thought whatsoever that it
might be full of Errors By some goob
that didn't key you know entering key
data that doesn't care so um this is
what you're doing just a whole bunch of
internet people that don't care so
that's one thing you can do is call them
two or three four times maybe they'll
take it off again the other thing you
can do
is with any debt on your credit report
you have the right according to Consumer
Fair Debt or Fair Credit Reporting Act
federal law to dispute in writing any
item on your credit bureau report
if they do not
repair
the error
within 60 days you have the right to
require them to completely remove it
the whole item as if it never existed
okay and so uh what I would do is just
dispute this item send it to Experian
return receipt requested so you have or
FedEx so you have a date of delivery
proof when the 60 day started okay you
have 60 days from this date to prove the
accuracy of this item it is inaccurate
it should be a zero balance if you have
not corrected it within 60 days you will
be forced to remove it I will force you
according to the federal Fair Credit
Reporting Act write that down Federal
Fair Credit Reporting Act so any of you
that have an error on your credit report
that's how you that's how you get the
error fixed now here's what normally
happens in the real world not the land
of Law and a theory in the real world
when you do that almost never so
Experian will send it out to the loan
servicer navient or whoever it is then
right
you know the the loan servicer is almost
always too incompetent to respond within
60 days
so Experian will hear nothing back from
them to correct the error within 60 days
and so then you'll go back and go you
haven't heard anything take it off now
the problem with that is the next time
they download a batch the next quarter
it may show up again
yeah that's possible okay but and so uh
I you know I probably am going to go
ahead and do both I'd fire off the
letter Federal Fair Credit Reporting I
get the 60 days started and in the
meantime I start calling navient or
Sally May or whoever the flip this is
and just wearing them out
no that's is our new carrier now so it's
who
Nelnet oh yeah yeah great
yeah it's still not any better but I
mean no no have you called them yet by
chance have you already called it but
did you already call them I have yeah I
closed and they said zero on their end
so they're they're not sure why it shows
up like that is what they tell me
yeah well
here's what I'm sure of
you reported it to him wrong
that's what I would tell them so you
guys need to call them you need you need
to send a note over and tell them to
take it off
like now or I'm gonna fall suit on you
people
and by the way man what was your name
I'm gonna just you know I want to get
the person on the other end's name
because I won't blame you in the lawsuit
so you need to get off your assets and
get this fixed
right jack them up exactly Jack them up
because they deserve it and you know I'm
not gonna be you know I'm not gonna be
mean until they just persist in their
you know belligerent incompetence and
then we can turn it up we can turn it up
we can make we can make a hobby out of
you people you know and that's what I
would do I you know because you need to
get this off of there and the problem is
if you were dealing with normal human
beings you just call up and they go oh
my bad I'll call and get it off okay but
we're not dealing with normal human
beings you're dealing with student loan
servicers and credit bureaus and it's
just them it's like dumb meets Dumber
you know
and it's just God what an aggravating
industry it's just there's and it's just
so so that you know don't let me help
you guys with this life hack okay some
of you are going oh I've got bad credit
on there I could lie
and writing and dispute it they'll
probably never correct it so I can make
them take the whole thing off well that
may work but it'll be temporary until
they download next quarters
batch of data and then you'll be right
back on there so you've wasted all your
time so you've got to go to the root and
dig out the dandelion otherwise it's
going to keep showing up on stinking
Experian TransUnion whoever whoever
you're dealing with over here so you got
to get the thing dug out by the root and
the root in this case lives over at the
student loan service or God help us yes
by the way uh two things she's gonna be
okay she knows that but you just have to
stay with it so don't freak out if that
happens to you and also I gotta mention
again our student loan live stream event
we've got a free event coming up Dave
Ramsey Jade warshaw and Rachel Cruz
we're going to give you a lot of
Solutions on getting rid of your student
loans but none of them have anything to
do with that call none of them at all
but when we mentioned student loans I've
got to mention that because there's just
so many people that are underneath this
thing and it is coming it's like it's
like a freight train coming uh payments
in September interest starts accruing in
September payments due in October yeah
it's so that's a reality coming to a lot
of people I don't I think Piper moved to
Washington DC so now it's time to pay
the piper there it is I'm just thinking
I was wondering where your guy liked
that I like that I think he's got a new
address his new zip code is DC that's
right you got to pay the piper now yeah
and uh uh I'm sorry guys some of y'all
are really facing some hard times but
we're going to help you the name of the
company's Ramsey Solutions why because
we got some solutions none of them are
magic that's right none of them are easy
but they all work so it's that easy
that hard yeah go to ramsesolutions.com
student loans sign up for that free live
stream why do they make it so hard to
pay off debt you know they make it easy
to get but that whole call illustrates
they make it real easy for you to get
into debt any type of damage credit card
they don't want you to have it paid off
that's right collecting the interest
that's the point we have that navient
former employee
you know with her identity held on
borrowed future documentary yeah talking
about how they train them to
intentionally screw up the loans so they
stayed on the books and they kept
collecting interest oh man they trained
them to do that they're freaking Crooks
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
time
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Ryan is in
Hattiesburg Mississippi hey Ryan welcome
to the Ramsay show
hey Mr Ramsey Mr Coleman thank you both
for taking my call today sure what's up
so we are in baby step four five and six
me and my wife and
we've been married for almost two years
and found out yesterday that we have the
baby on the way yeah all right
thank you sir appreciate y'all
um so my question today is this
um I know I've heard in previous shows
that you recommend to us pause the baby
steps when we have a baby on the way
um
but should we pause baby step number
four are investing no if we have no
you've got them that would be if you're
in baby steps one through three where
you don't have any money
but now you've got a fully funded
emergency fund
yes sir yeah how much is in your
we got 15 000. okay you're fine you got
good health insurance to cover labor
labor and delivery
yes sir and I'm actually one of those
guys that has an emergency fund for my
emergency fund so we have about six
grand and a another savings account so
we already have the money you got twenty
one thousand dollars laying around to
cover deductibles and whatever else you
got good health insurance you don't you
know you what we what we're talking
about when we push pause is when you
have just no money you got a thousand
dollars in the account and you're trying
to pay off debt well you don't need to
be there with a baby on the way so you
push pause and pile up cash build up an
emergency fund essentially right and
then you push play again and start
reducing your debt after baby comes home
and mommy and baby are healthy uh but in
your case you're in baby step four five
six you're already there so no you don't
need to do that
okay well that's that's good to hear
because I really didn't want to lose
that momentum when it comes to investing
so yeah you're doing great and now you
get thinking about opening up a college
fund in nine months good
yes sir yes sir and we're we're excited
uh about John deloney's new book we're
we're excited about uh purchasing that
and getting that in October so we uh
definitely appreciate all you guys and
what y'all do but uh we just wanted to
know about that because we didn't know
if we needed to pause or if we needed to
uh keep on going because yeah I think
you're in good shape brother
congratulations thank you thank you for
calling in McKenzie is with us in Tulsa
hi MacKenzie how are you
hi Dave's doing great thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
well I'm active duty military and my
husband's a stay-at-home dad at this
time due to my career our family is
expected to move at least five times
over the next 15 years or so we don't
want to be long-term renters but how do
we get in the housing game and build
equity at this point you don't you
should be a long-term Runner with rare
exceptions I would I would invest in a
mutual fund build you up a house fund so
at the end of 15 years you can just pay
cash for one
get a mutual fund aside and pay yourself
a house payment into that but um you do
not want to be buying you're going to
lose your butt Mackenzie jumping in and
out of houses every two or three years
by and large and because the equation is
the house usually in three years and
unless it's a very unusual real estate
market does not go up enough in value to
be able to sell it and break even you'll
lose money number one number two most
military markets if it's a if it's a
small town and it's largely the economy
of the town is largely supported by
military there's always a flood of
military houses on the market so there's
always extra Supply and so they don't
appreciate and it's hard to sell
now there's exceptions to that
properties either I'm sorry
no rental properties either no you don't
want to be long-distance landlording
across in in military markets everywhere
you've been stationed oh no that's a
nightmare
no and then talk about having a house
torn up my God the Harley Oil will get
changed in your living room you know no
that's that's the last thing you need to
do you don't want to be in the rental
market that way that's that's that's
rental property by default not by plan
um now there's a few markets it's an
exception you know if you were in
Virginia which is the largest naval base
in the world right you've got enough
you've got a big enough economy there
that those houses in the D their
proximity to DC and everything else
would they'll they will appreciate or
San Diego you're doing Navy and you land
in San Diego you're probably going to
appreciate enough in three years to get
in and out of it and actually make some
money but in none of these cases are you
there long enough to have that real
estate story of the house doubling while
you're there uh the only the only
question is can I get out of it in other
words is the market vibrant enough to
actually sell the stupid thing when I
leave and will it have gone up enough
that I can sell it and make money on it
and you can actually pull those
statistics it's average days on the
market Dom uh you have a realtor pull
them what's the average days on the
market for a house here
if you've got average days on the market
in nine days then you've got a vibrant
hot real estate market you can know you
can get rid of it when you get ready to
leave you got average today's on the
market of 270 days that's a nine month
sit no
and some of these markets will have that
no you can't that means you're stuck
you're going to become what's known as a
motivated seller and get yourself in a
pinch I know it's aggravating it's but
it's part we work with military we work
with military for 30 years all over the
world and we we love you guys we
appreciate what you do serving your
country and the last thing we want you
to do is get stuck in a stupid house
this is not a popular opinion is my
guess but I would take advantage of
military housing base housing when you
can I know it's not desirable for
everybody but you've already decided to
make this long-term commitment to serve
and to your point Dave if you take
advantage of that and you're investing
in a mutual fund in your entire career
you're going to come out with a massive
massive payment on a house maybe able to
buy something cash and I think that's
the long-term thinking that if I was in
the military I would be thinking about
there you go Michael is with us Michael
is in Fort Collins Colorado hey Michael
how are you
good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
uh real quick get to the point near your
system uh my fiance and I are getting
married in a month we just purchased the
house
um I had a house before we came into the
relationship so did she
um I just sold my place her thing about
putting hers on the market and we don't
know whether to put on the market or
keep it and use our funds together to go
towards our new house
I was doing like I said it was a new
year program and didn't know I was doing
the whole Dave Ramsey thing but uh
pretty much so you were already a
responsible adult before you met us oh
yes
congratulations on the marriage good job
man so how much do you owe on your
current home that the two of you just
purchased
uh so the total home is eight hundred
thousand that's the mortgage
no no that's the price of the house now
what's the mortgage
oh uh on her house no your house
I just sold sir no the one the two of
you just bought
oh uh it'll be 2800 bucks
no honey the mortgage balance what do
you owe to pay it off 250. okay that's
what I'm after and the other house we
owe 250 I sold my house and I'm bringing
in 550. so you can pay it off well yeah
we got about uh
um should be about 100 from hers
so you got 650 000 cash and you have a
250 000 mortgage when hers sells yes and
so you pay off the mortgage right
oh yes okay then what
uh well
we do have a small car loan on her
Explorer and that's gone
um
so what's your question you're debt free
when you get married and sell her house
right
no sir I don't think you're
understanding you're right I'm not uh
you got 550 000 oh you put that down on
the 800 000 house already yes sir
you're right I wasn't understanding I
thought you were sitting with a half
million dollars cash okay so one more
time you owe 250 on your house how much
is she gonna get in her hand when she
sells her house about a hundred ah which
would reduce that by a hundred you still
owe 150 other than the fact you need to
pay off the student loan first
we'll be coming to the table about 650
on a 800 000 home
you haven't closed on the new house
uh we close in about a month Oh I
thought you told me you already bought
it okay no it's what we did it's a brand
new build but we put our earnest money
down we just haven't we just haven't
closed okay yeah so yeah here's I want
you to pay off all Consumer Debt first
build an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and pay the rest of
it on the house and then let's
concentrate on paying off what little
mortgage you have it sounds like you're
gonna have about 150 000 bucks left over
give or take in a mortgage and let's go
and get that paid off as fast as you can
the faster you have a paid for house
with the income the two of you together
throwing at it you're gonna be
millionaires
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Ken Coleman
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
he is the author of the number one
best-selling book from paycheck to
purpose on the Ken Coleman show they
talk every day about careers and jobs
and making more money doing something
you love and he's here to help you today
hey guess what right now we're going to
do a baby steps millionaires theme hour
what that means for those of you who
haven't been with us before when we're
doing that we're only talking to
millionaires this hour real millionaires
not your broke brother-in-law or your
commune honest college professor we're
talking to real millionaires about where
real money comes from we want to hear
from you if you have a net worth of one
million dollars or greater let me help
you with this because some people are
confused the definition of a millionaire
is not a feeling it is not a moral
construct
it is not an income there's only one
definition of a millionaire when your
assets minus your liabilities equal one
million dollars or more you are a
millionaire
well you don't have a million dollars
cash don't need a million dollars cash
when your assets minus your liabilities
equals a million dollars You Are by
definition a millionaire well that's a
net worth millionaire that's a redundant
statement
there's only one kind of millionaire a
net worth millionaire that's the only
way you measure million dollars I
watched an idiot U.S congressman the
other day say well he makes a million
dollars a year he's a he's a millionaire
no you that is not what a
millionaire is how'd you get in Congress
unbelievable but yeah so no the the I
don't it's well that's not enough money
it's not a question of how much money it
is it's a question of is it a million
dollars no one should have that much
money this is not a moral construct it's
an accounting function do you have a one
million dollar net worth or greater we
can discuss all the other stuff but
that's the definition of millionaire if
you fall in that category we'd love to
talk to you and we don't want to talk to
your Brook brother in law with an
opinion who doesn't know how to vote
correctly we want to actually talk to
real millionaires that's what we're
doing so you can find out how to be one
someday and we in the process
um destroy all the mythology the lies
around the subject of Building Wealth in
America today so let's learn how it
really happens Cynthia is a millionaire
she's in Hartford Connecticut what's
your net worth Cynthia
1.1 million perfect just over the line
all right give me a little breakdown by
category of that 1.1
okay I have a uh 300 000 home in Texas
that's where I'm from and I have a 300
000 home here in Connecticut where I
work and the the remaining balance is in
my 401k so 600 so about 500 in your 401k
yes excellent how old are you
you too cool how much of this money did
you inherit none zero and since you've
been working what's your best year of
income and your worst year of income
my worst year of income was when I first
started nursing at about 60
and my best year was 285 000. whoa wow
travel nursing huh
I did do travel nursing and now I I do
home care I'm a psychiatric nurse and I
work in home care
okay so your degree in Psychiatry and
nursing or what no just nursing okay
excellent excellent all right and what
was your GPA in school
maybe a 2.9 okay good for you all right
so tell us uh we're talking to the 24
year old version of you
a quarter of a century ago
can she still become a millionaire if
she's a nurse yes what should she do if
she wants to do that
work as much over time as is offered and
invest your money right away and don't
buy a brand new car like I did out of
nursing school to start investing right
away because you have time on your side
very good very cool good for you so um
the biggest mistake you've ever made
with money is buying a new car
yes well you did pretty good that's
that's not there's a lot Dumber things
you could have done and that was that
was done but there's worse ones so way
to go kiddo I'm proud of you
congratulations do you feel any
different when you added it up and
realize you were a millionaire
um I do feel like there's a
Bill always been listed also my
shoulders I'm debt free I do not have an
ounce of debt so I still work every day
and knowing that my three kids have that
same work ethic that I do means the
world to me so you know they were paying
attention when they were younger I
worked all the time when they were
younger you know trying to pay off the
house pay down debt pay off my student
loans and now I have three kids that are
very ambitious and have a a great work
ethic I can imagine they watch their mom
kick it way to go very cool very cool so
Ken um one of the things we find if you
watch some of the ridiculous things on
social media which is a complete waste
of time
um but if you did you would find all
these people that claim that the ability
to build wealth in America today is gone
I call those people hope Steelers
because they're lying
whether they mean to or not I'm not sure
some of them mean to they have agendas
but basically it is a lie and you're
stealing people's hope when you tell
them it's impossible they say oh well
all wealth is now inherited so if you
don't have a rich Uncle you're screwed
or you know the only people to become
wealthier Crooks they steal the money or
the people that become wealthy are
famous entertainers or athletes that's
the only people or you got to have a a
4.4 GPA you have to be boy genius girl
genius right
um and the truth is that all three of
those things that are sprouted and
spouted by the anarchist leftists uh are
absolute lies yeah just statistically
well look at Cynthia so she goes and
gets a very good degree that has a
ladder attached to it she starts at 65
000 she's now making 285 thousand
dollars she promoted herself through
hard work and she got extra qualified
Patience by the way she didn't get an
extra degree she just stayed with that
Nursing degree now to psychiatric
nursing and is in the home care business
uh we did not ask her specifically my
guess is she has a small business that
she runs but regardless she increases
her income over a period of time almost
5X
which is really astounding in that
people think about nurses as that's a
good solid career I don't think the
average American if I went out on the
street with a crew and a microphone uh
would think that you could go from 65 to
285 and here it is she's just going
about her business that is serious money
you think about how many people never
make 285 000 and here's a nurse who's
absolutely crushing it so the American
dream is alive and well and being passed
on to her three kiddos she's living a
300 000 house in Connecticut this is no
Shack but this is no Mansion no
yeah yeah but her consumption is very
low that's correct that's my point her
need to impress others is non-existent
yeah well the easiest impressive
attributes of real millionaires boys and
girls listen carefully this is the
Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
steam hour if you have a net worth of
one million dollars or greater we'd like
to talk to you and learn about you so
that the listeners can be one too
you can figure out what the model looks
like what the template looks like and
the more you emulate it the faster
you're going to get there Gerald is with
us in Arizona hi Gerald how are you
I'm doing very well sir how are you
better than I deserve what's your net
worth sir
uh about 1.4 to 1.5 excellent give me a
little breakdown by category
we have about my wife and I have about
520 525
000 and 401K Ira you have oh pardon me
about 320 in higher interest CDs another
40 in two different savings accounts and
the rest is in property
okay so you got like 800 in property huh
50 to 700 yeah okay in real estate got
it okay how old are you
um 65. okay cool how much of this did
you inherit
none zero and your best year of income
your best year of income and your worst
year of income since you've been working
uh since I've been working my worst year
of income was my first year in the
Marine Corps so that was about four
thousand dollars way back when thanks
for your service list oh you're quite
welcome
the best I would say between my wife and
I had to be about 140 to 150. okay cool
what was your career
I was a painting contractor I owned my
own business for almost 30 years okay
and did you uh get a four-year degree
no I'm a high school graduate okay cool
what was your GPA in uh High School
oh about 3.4 I would guess on high side
okay cool good for you all right so as a
painting contractor and a marine you
were able to establish a 1.5 million
dollar net worth with no inheritance uh
by age 65. way to go
oh yeah we're happy we're relaxed more
importantly here here here what do you
tell people the key to causing this to
happen is I mean what if you got a young
person listening it's in the trades and
they've been told you have to have a
four-year degree or you're never going
to be anything and you've just proven
otherwise which is wonderful so what do
you tell that young person in the trades
can they become a millionaire and what
should they do
uh they can absolutely become a
millionaire or more the first thing I
would advise them to do is to take
advantage of any and every saving
opportunities for that compound interest
and be patient and everybody wants
something now you can do it if you think
and stay patient
that's it that's it the steady slow and
steady wins the race get rich quick it
doesn't work get rich quick cause you
have to start over too many times I know
I did that one I'm so dumb I had to be a
millionaire twice in this in this life
so um there you go I'm proof you can do
it believe me amen thank you for calling
in that's absolutely incredible you're a
hero
can that's uh uh our buddy micro would
like that shout out to the trade yeah
see what and and listen when you look at
today and you look at the trade
opportunities
uh it is a massive massive like six
eight Lane super highway to being a
millionaire because they're willing to
train you and they are willing to start
you very very quickly the time between
training to actually earning is is
almost non-existent with a lot of trade
schools give an example just I'll pick
one trade welding you know and you know
what the other thing I thought about
just what's that when you're a welder or
you're a painting contractor you're not
going to lose your job to AI no you will
not no you can't do it it's exactly
right it's exactly right and so the
point is is that you can actually get on
the job experience getting paid while
you're getting trained
and if you just juxtapose that you just
go okay wait a second that's one path
versus I've got to go to a four-year
school and I don't have the money for it
and I get in to debt over a hundred
thousand dollars versus I'm making fifty
thousand sixty thousand seventy five
thousand in the trades with an
opportunity one day to own your own
business I we've got to start to get rid
of the stigma Jara will tell you the
downside of that
you're going to get a callous well sure
do you know how many times that guy
couldn't feel his shoulders after a long
day of being on a ladder not just on
your tongue you're going to get a callus
not just on your thumbs you keyboard
Warriors but you're actually going to
get like a real callus on your hand yeah
you'll need a good chiropractor Chris is
in Los Angeles Chris what's your net
worth
the two million eighteen thousand Dave
so all right two million bucks all right
give me a little breakdown by category
okay retirement accounts 401ks 403b we
have uh 1.3 million uh house Equity 620
000 and then uh 100 000 in cash good for
you all right how old are you
62.62. and how much of this did you
inherit zero zero and your best year
working income and your worst year
working income
this year our combined would have been
380 and worst year would have been 25
000 right out of college cool well it's
been your career
I'm a International Airline Pilot
however I'm uh physically grounded uh
right now so um
not going to be able to fly to 65.
okay just uh uh the physicals you guys
have to take is that what you're talking
about
yeah every six months yeah as an airline
pilot you have to pass a physical and um
they discovered I have bone cancer so my
mom long-term disability till the end of
my career
okay yeah did you get a four-year degree
to be a pilot
yes I did okay in Aeronautics or
whatever okay and what was your GPA
uh three-point
three points okay
hey that physical that was required that
caused you to catch this early
it did
[Music]
I that's a a doctor sent me to an
oncologist yeah because we're the same
age and I don't do a physical every six
months I can promise you
so I'm just thinking that that might
have actually been a benefit did it how
did it help catch it early I mean is
that going to help you it did I mean I
must have been called uh early stage and
uh the it's a it's a chronic disease so
it won't go away but
um it did help it
um and the the problem with the FAA is
that my um the bone marrow uh cancer
causes me to be anemic which causes me
to be dizzy so flying is not I can't
even drive a car anymore so flying is
out of there yeah out of the loop okay
all right well I'm sorry for that that's
awful because you I'm sure you loved it
too
oh yeah yeah it was great I did a 23
years uh flying with the Navy and uh
with uh I can't say the name of the
company but um you know them while
they're in the South uh yeah a large
company and I've been with them for 23
years and you were flying the big boys
across uh on International then
LAX uh going to Sydney Japan Shanghai
and then on the East Coast we'd go to
Paris and Brussels and that's not not a
bad career after the Navy career thanks
for your service if you're we get a lot
of calls from people that want to be
pilots and
um the path is really rough if you don't
go through the uh the path there's a lot
of debt and of course the pilots start
out young Powers started making nothing
now as you know
um and if they don't go through the air
force routine or or some kind of a
military routine to get their hours then
it's a it can end up being a ton of debt
so do you have any advice for young
Pilots or somebody wants to be in this
career
yeah I do um uh my oldest son is
actually going through this he went
through civilian training which was very
expensive cost him seventy thousand
dollars to do that and then he figured
out quite quick quickly that uh
International Guard was a great way and
so he's
again with the International Guard
building hours and he'll move over to
Commercial and replace me eventually
yeah but I recommend that if if you're
not looking for a full-time
um military physician Reserve or guard
is the way to go yeah and National Guard
is good about paying for education as
well absolutely they got great programs
on that hey thanks again for your
service I'm sorry for you getting
grounded that's a horrible diagnosis but
the good news is you're in really good
shape financially and they caught it
early so that that's all a good part of
the story thank you for sharing your
story with us sir you're a hero this is
the Ramsey Show
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today this is a baby steps millionaires
theme hour we're talking to real
millionaires asking who they are what
they are how they did it so that you
have a model from real people who really
built wealth and not your broke
brother-in-law with an opinion not your
uh well whatever not not the wrong
people because a lot of people it's
amazing to me that broke people have a
lot of money have a lot of opinions
about money yeah and careful the the the
ones with a lot of followers on the Tic
Tac who tell you what being a
millionaire constitutes or how to get
there because they may not have any
money at all
that's entirely possible you may have a
million followers but not much money
your net worth is not measured in social
media footprint that's not the truth
help you with that and that's kind of
like uh the uh real insight that
Facebook friends aren't real friends who
knew yeah you want your tire changed at
two in the morning you don't call a
Facebook friend
I'll help you with that one all right so
yeah it turns out the virtual world is
not real who knows that's why they call
it virtual a lot of hype so anyway real
millionaires is what we're talking to
this hour the phone number here is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five a reminder that a millionaire is a
an accounting definition there's only
one definition there's only one kind of
millionaire everything else is a
modified version like I met a guy one
time who had one million dollars cash
and he had other assets too but he liked
to say I'm a cash millionaire well
that's true you're a cash millionaire
and you're more than a millionaire so
because your assets minus your
liabilities what you own minus what you
owe equals your net worth that is not
disputable you don't get to make up the
definition of a recession a recession is
two quarters of the gross domestic
product two consecutive quarters of the
gross domestic product going down a
recession is not a feeling that they
have on Fox News
it's not a feeling that the Biden
Administration has a recession is an
economic measure of data
and that you don't get to make up these
definitions people you just decide some
of you people just decide crap and
you're wrong so I'm just helping you
with this because it helps you that way
you don't end up following the category
of Hope stealer Tina on the other hand
is an actual millionaire in Myrtle Beach
South Carolina Tina what is your net
worth
it is one
excellent give me a little breakdown on
that
so about a million is then 401K between
me and my husband we have about a half a
million in real estate and property and
a little over four hundred thousand in
cash good for you excellent job how old
are you
50 years old 5-0 and how much of this
did you inherit
that happens but
I'm not even going to comment on that I
have relative listening
that's fabulous all right so zero and
what's your best year of working income
your worst year of working income
so my worst year I started working at
that have been uh this year at uh
roughly
400 and
80 000. good for you what do you do for
a living
I work in healthcare as a HR
professional wow okay and I also serve
on several paid boards I can imagine
nice and uh what you've got a four-year
degree in HR or Masters or what
I have a law degree actually oh you're a
lawyer okay good all right and what was
your GPA in law school
um it was about a
2.8 okay good for you perfect perfect no
I love this Dave I got to jump in here
because Tina I want to know I mean
you're very successful you're crushing
it how many times have people asked you
what your GPA was in law school in a
professional setting
you never okay just wanted to point that
out nobody cares what her GPA was they
want to know Tina what are we supposed
to do with this situation that's right
that's right good for you Tina we got a
mess here can you help us yeah that's
what they really want to know right
that's all right yeah
HR is Greek for mess yeah
oh my gosh wow wow okay what advice do
you have for the younger version of you
can she still do this and uh what should
she do to be you when she grows up
the opportunity to talk to young people
all the time and one of the first things
I do is always by then Total Money Maker
or my my niece is mine I knew I loved
you
graduated from college
um I always send them Total Money
Makeover because you have to educate
yourself that's one thing that I didn't
have I didn't know I'd have anybody who
taught me about money and spending and
debt and so I try to pass that gift on
to the younger generation so they're at
least aware amen amen in order to build
wealth what do they need to do
tactically with money what's the plan
really stay out of debt is is to me the
the biggest thing is staying out of debt
not trying to keep up with Joneses yeah
a way to go you're amazing I'm honored
to talk to you hero very very very well
done okay we did the largest study of
millionaires ever done in North America
my friend Tom Stanley who passed away a
few years ago his daughter Sarah has
continued his work wrote a book in 1992
called The Millionaire Next Door
he studied 750 millionaires he was a
marketing professor at Georgia State
University and he sold eight bazillion
of those books and became the
millionaire next door but uh that book
was extremely popular but the critics uh
the the leftists all said oh well who'd
never take statistics classes 750 is not
a large enough sample size to draw the
conclusions of where millionaires really
come from however it is statistically
significant and it is actually
excellent research but these are people
that don't know me so when we got ready
to do this 30 years later
we said all right 30 years later let's
re-look the idea where do millionaires
come from let's survey millionaires I
said 750 is statistically significant
but we know the leftists aren't going to
like it the Communists aren't going to
like it when we say that America is not
so broken you can't win so we better
have more than enough let's go let's
just go 10 times statistically
significant let's study 7 500
millionaires well we got carried away
and we ended up surveying and studying
10 167 of them and to we can't find
anybody that studied anywhere near that
larger sample size or the data that it
says tightly roped in our research
technique and methodology was airtight
to the point that if you don't agree
with the conclusions of this study you
are what's known as wrong okay that's
how that type this data is so here's an
interesting one
98 of millionaires that's all of them
when asked the question
can you become a millionaire today in
America said yes
well of course they did
they're millionaires I mean ask a guy
who rides a bike
do you believe people in America can
ride a bike today 98 will say yeah yeah
I can write you know I rode a bike the
other guy rode a bike you're gonna ride
a bike I mean because you've done it
people who haven't done it are the ones
that doubt you know that's the thing 69
of Americans when we study the general
public ask the same question only 69
believed it was still possible so it
turns out belief
causes action if you don't believe
saving money will make you rich then why
would you save money
so first you have to believe that it
works and then you take action on that
belief so belief is part of the equation
the other thing of course is this famous
thing of well all money's inherited
79 of millionaires inherited precisely
zero so far today we've talked to four
they've inherited precisely zero another
five percent of the millionaires we
talked to did get an inheritance but it
was mathematically so small that it
would not cause you to become a
millionaire like Grandma left them 5 000
bucks
that kind of stuff okay another five
percent received a substantial
inheritance after they were already
millionaires so it obviously didn't
cause them to become a millionaire like
you might got 250 000 bucks but you
already had a net worth of 2.5 so let me
help you with a 79-0 five small and five
after that's 89. that's nine out of ten
of America's millionaires did not become
millionaires because of inherited money
when someone tells you that they are at
a minimum wrong at a maximum lying
you don't have to inherit it you have to
do the stuff to get there though
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
our scripture of the day Romans 5 4-5
patience produces character character
produces hope and this hope will never
disappoint us Thomas Paine said
reputation is what men and women think
of us character is what God and the
angels know of us Christian is with us
in Michigan Christian what is your net
worth
hey Dave I'm at 1.1 excellent give me a
little breakdown on category
so it's in about 900 in real estate
about 180 in Investments and between
vehicles and cash about 75. gotcha how
old are you uh 32. wow young one today
okay good how much of this did you
inherit
uh nothing just just wisdom zero all
right and what's your best year working
income your worst year working income
between my wife and I uh combined
starting out about 60 and this year
opens our best at uh hold for about 200.
excellent good for you well done and
what's your career sir
uh I'm in actually landscape sales okay
very good you got a four-year degree
I do
um before you're in uh business in
business okay excellent what was your
GPA
3.1 excellent good for you okay cool
cool well you did this quick what do you
attribute being a millionaire so early
to 32 how do you tell people you did
that
yeah there's a lot of a lot of blessings
from God along the way and
um I mean honestly just listen to this
program a lot and seeing how other
people are doing it kept that drive
going there's lots of times we wanted to
just go do fun stuff everybody else but
I mean really just we kind of knew knew
what we want in life and the dreams we
have and this is kind of the way to have
that so house has paid off
houses paid off and it's worth 900. how
old were you when you paid your house
off tee the house off this year it's
worth about 7.75 and uh we've got a uh
another house that we own two and uh
that's kind of a rental income my wife
runs that business and I'm working on
that one too so this actually the end
this year we got our house paid off okay
so that in your case is a larger portion
of your net worth and so to say it
contributed to your net worth no it it
is a lot of it absolutely yeah yeah well
done man well done how's it feel
I thought it'd feel a little more like
we hit it we're there but I mean now
that I'm talking to you it feels a
little more real uh
it feels good I can't wait to see what's
what's next I hear you well
congratulations sir yeah you know it's
Christian I got to ask you this uh it's
less about the status of being a
millionaire and it's more about the
feelings that come with the peace and
the options you have is that fair to say
100 that's just what what can we do how
can we love others and how can we
explore and just yeah kind of live a
little bit more yeah yeah it doesn't
change the way you feel as much as it
changed the way you see the world and
perspective yeah it feels nice but it
boy I tell you you know I'll tell you
who's not struggling with inflation
right now as Christian
[Laughter]
because it's squeezing a lot of
Americans but I do want to point out
yeah
he's not stressed out about inflation
yeah congratulations sir very proud of
you well done Tammy is in Michigan Tammy
what is your net worth
uh 1.6 million excellent give me a
little breakdown by category
1.1 in retirement 300 000 cash 100 000
in our home and a hundred thousand in
our business excellent okay how old are
you
54. excellent how much your husband's
58. how much of this did you inherit
10 000 and we use that as a down payment
for a truck
which is our business lately
uh no that was in 96. do you remember
your first Fox Business News I think it
was your first one show I remember doing
Fox Business and I remember but I don't
remember the the content of the show no
thank you
uh yeah we were a caller and we sent you
a picture of our truck in our house uh
we are those people okay I love it I
don't know that I don't know if that was
08 or 09 yeah when that was that was
about that was about when it was
excellent yeah very cool so you
inherited zero what was your best year
working income no we inherited ten
thousand I'm sorry ten thousand I'm
sorry yeah down payment on on our first
record and uh income your best year and
worst year
uh best was 134 000 adjusted gross and
worst
War
what were the careers
driver we own our truck and trailer and
we drive it together as a husband wife
team
we've also been Farmers ah gotcha okay a
four-year degree or not
I have one and Nick has a trade school
degree okay all right what was your GPA
three points
good for you very cool all right so
being a farmer and a truck driver by 54
years old
with only inheriting with ten thousand
dollars which obviously does not make
you a millionaire uh you end up with a
1.6 million dollar net worth
um can people still do this today
yes
yes what should they do if they want to
be you
uh if you keep track of your numbers and
make sure your equipment is in good
shape if you own your own truck if
you're a driver definitely
um you need to automatic investing that
was a big thing with us treat it like
it's a bill
and same page as your spouse which is
easy to do when we're driving a truck
side by side you can't get away from it
yeah and we kept our nose to the
grindstone and we had a goal of being a
millionaire
wow wow good for you guys yeah having a
goal that's a good thing people don't
bring that up enough yeah Tammy when did
you hit when did you hit it what age did
you guys actually get there
oh oh wow I remember hitting 500 in
2016. we probably hit it we hit it in
2020. maybe 2019. so roughly 50. that's
pretty amazing and again
and in four years I've almost doubled it
yeah now since then so that's that's the
way that works way to go Tammy way to go
you guys I'm proud of y'all very well
done Heroes so um
Ken we didn't talk to anyone who stole
the money no no Crooks
uh we didn't talk to anybody who was a
Hollywood star or a country music star
or other kind of music star no you're
right
um we didn't talk to anybody who
inherited their money that made them a
millionaire uh we didn't talk to anybody
that had over a 4.0 GPA the highest was
a
3.6 Hertz right yeah yeah 3.6 3.4 2.9
3.5 you got to be smart enough
but not too smart apparently
um you don't have to be a rocket surgeon
I mean you just got to be able to you
know a rocket surgeon you just created a
new career there that's impressive I
know they fixed broken Rockets Rockets I
like that actually well it's the old
Alabama football player joke but yeah
yeah but the uh um yeah not you know
well here's not rocket scientists not
brain surgeons but rocket surgeons so so
uh our highest earner
had the lowest GPA as I'm looking at her
it's true our highest aren't the lawyer
the lawyer who's an HR HR she she had
she she edged out uh the other one by
about 70 000 but just to point out it's
about the quality of your work not what
you were as a student so very
interesting here as we look at all these
numbers and again so uh yeah uh
psychiatric nurse yep painting
contractor pilot HR professional that
was a lawyer landscaper truck driver
yeah how about that again I didn't see
medical doctor no uh
no professional athletes there no
celebrities by the way yeah no oh oh no
no social media influencer on this list
I just want to point that yeah although
some of them are doing very well they
are they are but the point here is that
the get rich quick is uh it can happen
yeah but it doesn't happen often yeah
it's just got very few Skittles and
rainbows involved right not much glitter
yeah it's just kind of like work yeah is
what it sounds like you know this is uh
you got to do your stuff man so um well
that's what the book baby steps
millionaires is about the uh study that
we talked about earlier in the hour the
larger study a millionaire has ever done
the white paper for the studies in the
back of the book baby steps millionaires
so if you want to know more about what's
really going on in the culture with
wealth building
oh we probably know more about anybody
right now and you pick that book up it's
the number one bestseller it'll help you
get going on it can good show today that
puts the sour in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
this episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsey Baby Steps
go to ramsesolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]